welcome to this video papal Papa papa
okay 29 from Indonesia right that's
Pauline what the heck I need to check
this now just let Indonesian flac look
compared to the Polish flag that's
really really not good okay the Kings
Indian what is he doing reinventing
theory here no let's play my own line
three line hmm interesting that's an
interesting way to play okay try to
quickly prepare before now you can
actually play that now maybe I'm I
thought this wasn't too great but maybe
Queen a3f that's interesting in fact c5
coming very quickly okay well I need to
I need to get some counter player
how well maybe 97 now this could have
been interesting effect with some Cabot
okay the 97th it's not really preventing
c5 so I might as well play this some
more aggressive move yes might be a tall
95 95 gives away a pawn but its not New
compensation whatsoever okay I'm
interesting c5 takes on c6 knight c6
yeah that looks very fishy for black now
better not to pre move knight c6 okay I
came so are his intention is to take on
d6 am sacrificing interesting now but
that's not entirely clear 96 I'm not
sure that this was the right decision
for for him yeah but it's this this is
so great I mean I understand that it is
interesting but is it great the night
here hmm mighty 7s probably Queen 85
write a six and that stuff does not lead
to anything okay lets them get the night
over here now f5 blunders 296 okay
okay night afore salt some nonsense
okay and that's not easy at all this
move had an idea I want to play night
age 72 to g5 activating the problem is
this oasis 96 after at five okay yes but
is it so great i mean i'm not sure
really
so Bishop just take it out with the
bishop and now this nightie for hanging
and I don't know it could be a win for
white of course but it also might give
me a very strong cable to play with my
remaining pieces I mean those nights are
not especially passive oh no no this is
not going to work and I cannot believe
it let's see I came 23f foyer the dark
squares are just just totally totally
totally weak
okay so he's just ignoring that yeah but
besides this this is hanging yeah I can
also just take here for example or queen
bee 6 with Queen III to come now this is
like actually quite strong okay so now
let's check how to meet this here
checking an idea for yeah this is
leading to a checkmate yeah this is
leading to a bit I don't I don't think
he can defend this 90 for him the made
only to that sense that's not possible
to defend well it's it's made in a
couple of moves after King situ with
2392 the typical mating pattern check
queen bee three queen bee was madness
yeah this I think white was in very good
shape of course I mean I was probably
totally outplayed but he shouldn't
really sacrifice I mean it's not
necessary at all and I'm not sold on
this night maneuver I mean I think up to
here he did he did a fine job I guess
and if you know play precisely you
should really preserve a very nice
position for white the computer suggests
g3 which is certainly not a bad news
covers this ki square laos possible
Bishop g2 but also Bishop to e2 that
looks like that it looks fine I mean
well this does not spoil it yeah but not
sure that this whole plan is soham so
helpful yeah now the computer is already
skeptical this is not really working and
if you need to return all then this
whole thing hasn't airily hasn't really
worked out at five is an interesting
move here this was one idea of this
night transfer to g5 that II six is
covered and here this is in fact quite
okay for black yeah typically
complicated Kings Indian position no
idea what what really has happening but
this I think is just just not working
yeah minus eight that's quite a lot you
aren't here ruchi one is a bit better
but okay yeah I can also take the rook
but I thought that this should be enough
yeah minus 11 ok that's assuring and
hear that since I made really made
maiden comp gives made in eight
check me out yeah the calm place jack
place those moves to delay them made a
couple of couple of moves yeah that was
probably quite bad for black I guess
this this is an interesting idea a three
here I have seen this before a three
input can maybe maybe I need to do
something else here this this is very
interesting because now you're white is
threatening before and I mean I must
play a fight really there is no other
move before and then this is really a
very nice for why to this position very
interesting way to play so what is the
main issue Bishop a 6 an 8 a-6 Bishop e3
may be here if I've immediately maybe
each five immediately hip as he hasn't
played Bishop g5 maybe maybe but this is
definitely is quite good for white very
interesting line alright thanks for
watching